Hello. Hello
and welcome to this demo video of how to install
Cognotic on Windows. Hello. Welcome to this demo, welcome
to this demo video of how to install Cognotic desktop
on Windows. Simply go to cognotic.com. And
download the installer file or you can go to GitHubb
under releases and see all of the installer artifacts. I'm
going to click on download for Windows. Save this file
Because it isn't commonly downloaded, you may have to manually
keep the file before you open it to install
it. Install it like any install
it like any desktop application. And
there we go. Next
we need to configure the application. We go to Cognotic
In the start menu, run it. Now, this is a
server-based application, so when you run Cognotic from the Start
menu, this is starting the server. You have to go
to the taskbar, click the server icon for Cognotic, and
that will open. Browser page. From there, you need a
login. This is a system local login that's used to
secure your API credentials. So, if you don't have
one already, you can easily register. For this, I'm just
going to say Far. And for password I'll say test
Weak passwords in my for. It will warn you
about weak passwords, but it will allow them, except for
space, it won't allow space when you register. It
will launch a confirmation dialogue, which unfortunately sometimes doesn't come
up. On the top, so you have to find it
with Alt tab. This is to prevent people over the
internet, uh, for example, potentially creating and using your
service. You say yes. And
now we have access to the web UI. Next
we need to go to settings to add our API
key. We add provider. It supports a number
of different providers, but I mainly use and therefore mainly
recommend anthropic angioma. Cut
this part, enter an API key, save
settings. Don't save that in the password manager
and now we can test with basic chat. Oh, we
need to re refresh the page first. Test with basic
chat and we see haiku, haikuanthropic. That means the models
were discovered. It probably works, but let's do the full
test. Hi. All right, now
we have Cognotic fully installed, configured and tested, and we
are ready to run one of the applications.